vous êtes devenu une vraie fille
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus féminine non
oui oui et oui pas parler jean bon sinon
lauras à la main vous avez des talons
des talents portée de méchants né chez
moi ouais c'est difficile de marché que
telle non je vais arriver ouais vous
dont 10 super bien et l'avenue cure
aussi voilà ça va vous voulez ses
invités au restaurant maintenant non non
non quand même pas quand même passé
quand même temps de la salle de bains a
le moins de temps possible c'est quand
même pas je pense
vous pleuré quand vous casser un ongle
jacquard tout le temps
simple jeu est une vraie femme vous avez
peur d'avoir 40 ans maintenant dans away
j'espère juste y arriver dès la wii
avec un paquet de clopes par jour marqué
je n'étais pas toutes les chansons ouais
c'est une vraie femme vous raté vos
créneau jeu
[Applaudissements]
j'ai dit que j'étais dangereuses comme
une femme au volant président inverse
avec oui nous rêver au prince charmant
oui ah oui je serai commencera seulement
voilà il ajouté ouais j'sais pas
brillant bah oui d'où le nom
il doit être comment voulez le trouver
soit brillant jeu qu'ils soient cultivés
intéressant quel âge je sais pas 26
quelle conne
et toc
maintenant que vous êtes une femme vous
écoutez abba avec des bigoudis sur la
tête n'ont
pas encore complètement ce truc là vous
voulez combien d'enfants 2 minimum parce
que le minimum mais je vais pas d'enfant
unique alors comme vous êtes devenu
presque une vraie femme ils ont presque
une ménagère de moins de 50 ans une m -
50 comme on dit sur les chaînes
commerciales on vous faire l'interview
page de pub vous n'êtes pas
[Musique]
diam's est ce que vous pensez que vous
le valez bien
oui je le vaux bien pourquoi vous levez
vous
pour affronter la juste ouais ouais on
va être un coup de boule
en ce moment vous avez un ami du petit
déjeuner
ouais
des frontistes des canucks ouais c'est
bio j'aime bien les frosties de québec
c'est quoi votre manière préférée de
faire crac-crac
itunes cracotte
ça doit être gay je
veux profiter de cet écran pub produire
peu de citron
dites moi le quelques heures c'est votre
affaire non
vous êtes plutôt au zéro tracas zéro
blabla
zéro blabla zéro blabla ouais trop de
tracas qu'est ce qui vous fait rugir de
plaisir
l'amour
quand même quand même vous l'avez trouvé
là non et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux